recording in progress okay hello
everyone we are doing a Wilson language
design review part of our incremental
language development series and we have
a variety of topics which were thought
in the gosh when was it the 2015 type
time frame to be low hanging so let's
take a look
we might actually start with the second
section since we're waiting on Carlo to
show up and we have shorty here
image interpret so that's a that's the
reverse
I I think this is just a toy it's kind
of the reverse
of what people think we should do
which is you know make one of these um
text to image
generators
it's the can you make a sentence about
what's in this image type question
are you with us
I see I didn't remember that now that
you say that description that makes
sense
there are captioning techniques for
images if you think that's something we
want to do I think it could be a good
either an intern project or neural
network conversion project or something
like that I think that's what we I mean
look if there's a neural net that just
does something reasonable here we could
try it okay
I think it starts on the neural net
repository and maybe the function
Repository
and if it seems to be doing very useful
things we can consider it as a system
function makes sense
okay Carousel and image carousel
so
that is a
just like we have things like tab View
and so on Carousel will be a carousel
view of a bunch of images
seems useful to me I think it's more
like a front-end play than it is
something else
comments from people
yeah I mean I assume we'd have similar
set of concerns with like image collage
or
something like that well I'm thinking
this is more like look I mean it's just
like come
um
let's see uh
you'll spell it while it got it now
um
okay so let's say we have this and now
we say tab View
of that
so you know this is a way of viewing
them and what I'm imagining here is that
Carousel is just another view type where
it's on you know you you have a forward
button and a back button right how about
this animate of that
and we have animated image
well that's fine I mean that's close
it's just not quite the same thing
right so I mean we we've almost got
exactly this I just think it would be a
useful thing to have to just say make a
carousel
in which
you know you can go forward and backward
right it's a very simple thing
I mean this is something maybe the uh
John fultz on the front end team need to
opine
I kind of agree because I think it's not
just useful for images if you have
anything it should it better work with
any expression
um
okay
yeah yeah right no I mean it would just
be a carousel I don't know why image
Carousel is separate
I think this is a useful thing I don't
see why we wouldn't want to have it okay
yeah we'll put it on our slate if we
have something pretty similar in the
function Repository
okay yeah I put in chat if you want to
look at
that's some more so you can drag the bar
on top and it's yeah it's kind of nice
actually yeah I use this all the time
it's really it's a really helpful
utility
well maybe we should build this in
I mean something very much like this I
mean look at the graphic design of it
but I like this and this is kind of cool
I mean you know there's another one that
I use all the time which is
um
uh what is it called interactive
selector
I'm an interactive list selector
that's a slightly different thing and
maybe not not so
generally relevant but this would be
very useful I mean this is a pretty
common thing one wants to do is to
examine a whole bunch of things
um
I mean we could yeah
I okay
this is as I say
yeah I mean I don't know whether this is
for this team
or
it seems useful to me and this will need
some graphic design in ux to really make
it as spiffy as it could be
okay yeah we'll bring that back around
when we look at Wolfram function
repository stuff as well
well I don't know oh how interesting is
it how hard is it to do I mean
you know it's like if you want a program
that can I mean look every old system
now comes with many different kinds of
beeps
yeah I think the project is really
curating a whole bunch of people that's
what it is what it is do you do you want
us to spend that spend time on that
I mean that that um the only question is
where on earth does that get put I mean
maybe I have no idea I mean we can
ask somebody is probably into this but
yeah go ahead what are you going to say
no the only other thing is that b party
also has a single one argument form uh
which is a message and I would have
thought the easiest way to generalize
that to be a named beep as the one are
the the first argument is the name of
the beep
yeah I would have thought so too
well one other thing maybe is that beep
I think does like the beep is at least
on Mac it's an OS beep like there's a
operating system setting where you can
set what kind of beep you want
ah well but then there are many
different operating system beeps so you
know we should be able to set I mean
they have different options but like on
Mac anytime an applicant if you that
there's like a single beep sound that
comes from all applications you know
when
when something deep worthy happens oh
why do I go why do I go to see it as a
notification
um oh I think it's in sound but I could
be wrong
it's middle uh yeah
sound effects
at the top
yeah you have the boop beep
click on any of those you hear how they
sound
but it might it might change my beep
well yes you should change it back to
Boop when you're done
[Music]
oh wow
right I mean I I sometimes think it
would be nice if you had a different
sound just because like I'll often have
like either a MIT sound of sound note or
speak or beep or something like that so
that I can do other things and have it
let me know when it's done exactly the
default beep is that default beep is is
exactly what I want except that it means
so many other things on my computer I
know I know I know and you're always
looking around what just beeped right I
have a little utility I use all the time
that it's it's like Echo but instead of
printing it either does like a ding or a
or it says failed
Echo it returns
you know the the same expression and I
find it pretty useful for running the
background stuff
okay so what do we do here I mean we've
got beep with the one argument form
which has this kind of annoying
population the way the beat message
which I'm not sure
I mean
we could hack it and have certain alert
sounds
uh I mean look the first thing is to
curate some beeps
and I don't know this is not a common
thing that comes up in the company so we
don't have you know sound design
particularly as a thing
um we could try asking graphic design
whether they have a thought about this
or whether they know somebody you know I
mean I think um somebody could ask Andre
he's been into such things in the past
and maybe we can just find a person
who's into doing this
not seem reasonable
I think the two most important is like a
success and failure
so okay that would be really useful well
then and then we may need another name
then beep if we've already burnt up its
one argument form
so by the way what does Deng do does
ding make some reasonable sound yeah
yeah it's like you're like higher
pitched one like it's like a bit sound
of sound note or something or is it some
some more uh I think so yeah yeah yeah
it's simple
what are you talking about what is
different function there's there's a
resource function ding right ah okay
well I mean so you know we may be able
to have a name like ding
yeah so you can have beep and ding that
does seem a little bit um
uh weird but I think first of all let's
get these things designed I I see Avery
is commenting that Bob from video works
on music audio I I bet there are a bunch
of people in the company I bet we can
look up who knows what database and find
a bunch but we can certainly start there
maybe Avery could go try and chase this
and so whether we can find somebody who
is into doing this
okay and I and I agree that the things
that we need are you know we could have
something that's called a success beep
if it's called beeps so success ding
failure beep and I'm sure we can get to
know
you know an upbeat beep and a downbeat
beep and a um uh what other kinds of
beeps are there that are that are sort
of obviously
um
I mean I could imagine
a situation like Echo
where
actually this is a cool idea
um
something like this where you say it
won't work with beep as
as that name but let's say
um Echo beep or something like that
let's call it that where an expert there
is a beep deduced from the form of
expert
that is generated
I mean hopefully it's not too
intelligent if experts dollar failed
it'll go beep exactly and if that's
that's exactly what I have that's
exactly what I have yeah that right so
then this is a wrapper like Echo and and
possibly you know Echo beep could both
Echo and beep
does this return expert I think using
the term using the term Echo for audio
is awesome you know Echo problematic
yeah right
um that's the beep twice
right right it's off to the second time
right so okay so that's not a good name
but but I think this idea of a rapper a
beep rapper does seem useful to me
because that way if that's the case we
can then
you know if what we put in it because
right now beep itself returns null
probably
as it was built a long long time ago
right I'm sure it just returns null
yeah
like print I mean they're both wrong in
some sense
and the correct thing would be to have
it be a rapper and then the only
question is whether it beeps and
um and Echoes no not of the beat but I
mean and and print you know what I'm
saying
um if it also prints then Echo beep
might not be a bad name
well but but the printing is I feel like
there are cases where you don't want it
to print and then they're also uh you
know it's it's so easy just to say echo
of beak
um that point so so if we have a
I mean clearly we could
um
you know could we reuse beep
I don't know doesn't really sound like
it
maybe as an optional first argument
no no the first argument to beep
is a message but the question is
this is population the why the beep
dialogue
as opposed to
I mean I don't think it would be
terrible
to have beeps start returning its
argument as opposed to being null I'm
not sure that might break things I don't
know
um
I mean it's just such a nice name beep
is such a nice name
what other things are there like beep
that are
chime
that sounds too Bell like
um
let me see am I convenient
emit emit sound we got them it sounds
already a function
um oh yeah there it is
uh
well unfortunately ding has too many
other meanings by the way image sound
doesn't have a zero arc form so yeah but
we're not looking for such an argument
we're looking for one argument yeah what
I'm saying is that the image sound of
zero args maybe should beep
Maybe
um
yeah it just seems very you know like we
used up the good name yep something that
doesn't turn well I'm still not
convinced wait what's that we do perhaps
so in version Oh my God it's it's
actually fairly recent
I mean it's not um it's not older than
anybody here for example
um
what was updated 13-1
did the message get out at thirteen one
yeah the string argument was added I
think oh okay well we could just dug
ourselves into a hole then you know what
we could reverse that I think we should
reverse that I think it was a mistake
that's not that big a deal if we just
added it it's not got a bunch of burnt
in code based on that it's not
devastating
but it would still return null
oh no why oh just because that actually
goes back to version you know six or
whatever but I can't believe any broken
clothes could return no because what
else could it return other than like
sequence open close but beep of X could
still return X all right I see yep I
think this is what we should do I think
beep of expert should return a beep that
is suitable for Expo
and should return expert
and in terms of putting something into
the message window
we need a good mechanism
for you know I mean we need this notify
function
that
you know puts up a notifier on the
screen because that's the thing you know
you're running I mean this is a typical
thing you're running off screen it's
this that and the other you want one of
these notifiers that's an operating
system Notifier
or notification or whatever to come up
and that's kind of like our out of
window print type thing
you know what I'm saying could somebody
investigate how we do that I don't know
what involves the front end team whether
it's just you know where it really
um
uh where it really comes from right you
know what I'm saying we want something
where you can
stop it in the repository with that I
just let's get in chat oh
um
oh well
wow you wrote this already
yeah that was a while ago
well I've been wanting this for just
millions of years
we have a manipulate version of Rick
that just outputs functions like this by
the bushel
except that this particular bushel seems
to have choked towards coffee
oh
um
actually yeah I was gonna say but
depending on what build this is I I
heard uh Todd mentioned in a meeting
earlier that there were you know various
flags for j-link that that need to be
updated
well listen I think we need this
function as a system function
okay yeah I can certainly check in with
John if there's anything related to the
front end system there too but it does
seem like there's right but if Rick has
already solved the problem
now
this these is an external service rig or
just it's making some system call
uh yeah I'm just using some Java Library
I I don't remember the details off top
of my head it's a while ago yeah we can
let's do a proper design review of this
I mean
this is very useful and by the way it
should also work in the cloud and things
like that yeah it's just completely
separate code
um okay yeah we'll put that on the
docket and do a quick sweep fine and
then I think we should plan on using
beep beep of Expo we should get some
sound design what kinds of things do we
want we want a success be a failure beep
um warning beep
yeah probably
uh low memory beep
that make any sense or something or how
will we even know that what would we
return what what thing when you feed it
in
I mean
you know is there a way of taking a
random expression
and
you know beeping about it
so I'm saying I mean like in other words
what's the difference between beep of
range of 10.
and beat them Rage of a thousand
and I would argue if we could get a nice
thing that has you know if it's 10 it's
you know it's kind of like
uh
well it will be an audio version of this
I mean we could do
um
uh kind of a a
sound I mean maybe this is crazy
I mean we could imagine something where
we take an expression and we try and
iconize we try and make an a sound icon
of that expression
does that make any sense to anybody
I think that's crazy fraud it's
something it's a discussion we had maybe
we tally like 11 years ago about
you know having having sonification of
things like I think at some point we
also discuss making sounds out of plots
and things like that which which is
actually a super nice idea because
sometimes you can hear things that like
yes we've been there before
in version two we introduced the
function play analogous to plot
it's never been a huge win well but play
is a little different but I think there
were very uh summer school projects also
like a decade ago yes that related to
this but you know yeah actually there
was one even pretty recently I think
show shows his name had a had a project
about this
hmm
well
but I think really I mean you know it's
it's like you're you added this to your
code and you're distracted by other
things and then you hear some weird
sound and you know it's like I think
it's much better if just you know have
like two like positive negative
something like that
fair enough it's like the sentiment of
our temperature you could add a second
argument like in close where it applies
a function to whatever it is but by
default I think
simple is better
right so basically
it's the sentiment of an expression
up or down type thing successful failure
that's what I'd want
fair enough
and I think for a future something like
compute with progress
um could incorporate some kind of a
beeping system because that seems to be
the most uh common use case that people
are using beepsaur
okay the other thing I can imagine is
you know if I want beep of a you know I
got a null list versus I got a bunch of
things out
I mean I don't know I can imagine you
know it's kind of like well I didn't get
nothing or Bob you know I got a bunch of
cool stuff here
am I making sense I mean that that seems
like it might be worth distinguishing
nobody's very convinced yeah I mean I
was trying to think of what are the
useful things to get audio-wise you know
the what I would think is either if
there's some you know the generic
fallback is either size of expression
you know we've got a bunch of data here
or perhaps something that is indicative
of how long it took but I don't know
that either of those are universally
useful
okay um
Ethan on our live stream is suggesting a
warning sound for us let's try it very
dangerous
that's kind of fun
did you hear that I think you need to
share the audio
share the audio through Zoom I could
hear it
it wasn't here like very faintly well
that's that's how do we audio amplify
how do we shoddy how do I make it louder
uh
just time something
the play times a number or no this is a
sound so that yeah that that went for
it I think we're only hearing it like
out your speakers in your microphone
kind of thing no no it's very quiet yeah
oh okay
let's see
audio settings
um
how do I do this
well anyway
you can um you can try it on your own
machine it's kind of cool so it's it's
fun
um okay
okay well
so I think what we're learning here I
mean we probably need to bring this back
after somebody's thought about it
but you know I can imagine true false01
things like that
I mean
now
I can imagine a null list being
different from something else those
kinds of things
I mean
this needs a little bit of sound design
because if it has
if there is a core kind of um
beep sound and then there's a little
tail to it somehow that is different
depending on these different cases then
you will not be confused about what kind
of you know what animal produced that
beep but nevertheless you will have some
hint from the tail of the beep so to
speak what the you know what was being
communicated there
anyway I really like having notify I
really like I this this is a good idea
to have beep be another thing like Echo
really useful idea
but I do think its default beep needs to
be something other than the generic
system beat where you're just confused
about what
no where it came from
so okay Avery if you can take that and
try and
feed that to appropriate people yep yeah
so do have Carlo here so if we want to
look at the first handful of items at
some point we can do that too well this
is what he gets for doing later we're
going to do shot his stuff first
um in my defense I'd never got the new
time for this oh okay I apologize yeah
for me so
okay
I'll try and go through this quickly
autotune
what is that again
shorty
um I again don't recall where this has
come from it's similar to pitch shifting
time stretching you know these are
effects that we're talking about not low
hanging in my opinion
and also not that important in my
opinion okay
I'm in
okay
image anonymize
now that's been a thing we've been
wanting to get done as a summer school
student project and so on I don't know
is that important
I don't think most of our use cases
people care about that particularly but
it would be a
I also a little bit worried about what
we sign up for and doing it so to speak
yeah have having a full coverage on
anonymization is probably
debatable forever yeah right right right
I think we should punt on this one too
okay photo enhance
people hanging for some things
on what kind of enhancements we're
talking about look red eye removal is a
thing of the past
yep
um
I mean it's relevant for legacy photos
but it's not relevant for anything new
you know I realized I haven't seen a
phone flash to take a picture in
millions of years
anyway that's what you get for high
dynamic range ccds or whatever they are
I think there's nothing I I don't think
this is a thing either do you agree
I do agree I think we have uh one lower
hanging function not low hanging but not
as high priority project I'm on our list
for face transforms maybe based on a lot
of neural networks for younger older
um and so forth I think something like
radar eye removal could be yeah wfr look
red eye removal is rather easy and
having a wfr for red eye removal would
seem useful to me yeah sure I agree what
about something for for levels like that
that
takes the histogram to something more
reasonable in case I thought we already
had that we already have a bunch of
things probably we do yeah we do I mean
it's a standard image processing thing
all right time scripting
I couldn't remember what was the topic I
don't know what that means okay here's
what this is and this is actually a good
idea and important and it dovetails with
a bunch of other complicated stuff about
Time series
and uh really this is the thing okay
this really should insofar as we've got
a Time series redesign going on this
should be looked at okay so what is this
this means
and it's also relevant to video
this is
okay when you do a video when you do
like a um
animation video for example okay let's
say and I think we have some somewhat
hacky Syntax for this right now if you
say I want to show this for for one
second followed by this for three
seconds followed by whatever else
see what I'm saying how do you do that
right now in video
multiple videos we have to trim and then
join them
no and what I'm saying is this when we
have animation video
okay we are taking you know there we've
got a function that we're doing this to
right yes but we also have a US what's a
a slideshow video
that's images oh here we go
foreign
any transition we haven't designed that
but we do want to add transitions for
um slideshows joining
um
and other functions
okay but look what this is and this is
probably a separate discussion separate
meeting this is something where the idea
would be just like we have geometry I
mean
roughly it's kind of like a graphics
where you're saying with with insets or
something where you say put these things
at these places on the screen
okay this goes along with
um
a thing I've long thought we should have
but now that we have video this actually
becomes more interesting
okay it's timed plot
which you might argue is just like
animate I suppose
what am I saying so if I say animate
well okay so if I say animate plot sign
X Plus t
x 0 10 comma t
0 5.
yeah I guess that's basically the best
we can do for a timed plot
and now if I say for that
if I say animation video
so painfully slow and why did it just
freeze that other thing
I don't know maybe that the progress
monitor was coming up
are we embarrassed how slow this is
a lot of it comes from rasterize we have
had discussions again or we are
restarting discussions again with the
front-end team about speeding up
rasterize
I mean I don't understand how this can
be so slow because the fact is you know
this is generating obviously
the operating system is generating a
raster at high speed here
yeah absolutely yeah that that's
something yuju is bringing up the fact
that perhaps we don't need to rasterize
anything anymore because we're
displaying rasters already
yes well quite and I mean look at this
it's got It's got all kinds of craft in
it
I don't know why it came out bigger and
I don't know why the why the frame is
wiggling
I think you should look at this I think
this has got bugs in it
the frame is weird the fact that it's
bigger is because you're on a high
resolution screen rasterize is giving
you the the pixel dimensions uh rightly
so
is twice as big as what you see in that
uh Graphics above
and video doesn't have anything we
cannot store anything like resolution in
videos like we can for images so it just
gets displayed twice as me why can't we
put in the video wrapper why can't we
put resolution information in the video
wrapper we can probably do something but
none of the video formats support
something like that image formats do
and we do save them correctly
so there's no exit for whatever for for
video in all those hundreds of video
formats
okay look look I I think I think more
needs to be looked at here and I do
think this thing about rasterization
needs to be solved because I I think
this particular case of animation video
we should be able to do unbelievably
much faster
I agree
right
and why don't you look at this
particular case
I'll send it to you
um
just uh
I have it
okay
um
okay all right so in terms of this I
think it's a separate meeting to discuss
symbolic timing wrappers and I don't
know maybe Jose has an opinion about
this because it also relate I mean there
are multiple things from temporal logic
to time series to sound to video
to
even things about historical countries
and things
go ahead I do see the connector with
temporal logic with construction such as
until so that we have two things
proceeding we could have I don't know
several images appearing at the same
time and then one disappears
another Texoma
right I don't see the the general
context here yet
I understand I think we need a separate
meeting about this this can be another
ild topic and let's bring this back with
again people from the time Series team
Etc need to be part of that
makes sense Avery
but in terms of this right now we've
just got some bug stories to you know
resolve here
yep
okay markdown was a priority project in
2015.
I roll
we talked about it in the import export
meeting we're gonna get to it at some
point we're we're thinking we can handle
it maybe the front end team not maybe
the front-ending team should be involved
when we're talking about whole notebook
import whole notebook export
um a lot of things
before that could be done just within
the import expertise needless to say
is this a is this another Rick
production
yeah it's it's just an early prototype
of something I wanted to flesh out at
some point but by the way you for some
reason this page has been miss built
look at that after scope it just dies
something is wrong with this actual page
yeah well it's not in the public
repository oh it's not just about Cloud
to play function
yeah I haven't actually submitted that
to the repository yet I was going to
work on it at some point
cool
well Shady there's a connection for you
there's some repositories specific to
like a table I think but not sort of a
general thing
I think it'll be nice to have by the way
I don't even know how would you generate
an HTML table
is there an easy way to do that
if I want to you know take
something from our table system our grid
system like this one yeah HTML fragment
in export on a grid does it just does it
yeah
okay
um
oh Connor has a thing for
marked down to notebook
huh well that seems relevant so he's
also been working on a notebook to mark
down kind of thing as well okay so then
fine so there's another connection for
shoddy here
sounds good I mean Conor is dealing with
that because he's dealing with packlet
tools and the interaction with Git and
GitHub and so on
okay let us return to uh color here
okay
this seems like a no-brainer
so so therefore we don't need to spend
our brains on it
export string with http
first time I hear of this
foreign
oh I see
it's for generating I'm a little
confused here but but an HTTP response I
see the point you've got an HTTP
response
and the question is I mean I don't even
know how this works but
what does the
you know when your computer contacts a
web or when you get back something from
a web server the raw stream of bits is
an ASCII string is that a true statement
um no it it depends it depends on the
Mind type
uh so you know they could return
something that is actually bites like
and it has an encoding in general in the
in mind type so
um
but the question here is what this is
asking is
is it is there a string equivalent or
maybe it's a byte array equivalent of
HTTP response because right now yeah
there is it's a it's if the string
equivalent is body it's property of HTTP
response and the byte equivalent is body
bites
but is that the whole thing
yeah pretty much except I mean one thing
that you might want but it's pretty much
what you are like the kid does is to
read also the Mind type and import it as
appropriate
well I assume that's what import does if
it's sent to an arbitrary URL that it
uses the mime type to decide what to
import it out so doesn't it yeah but
import cannot do a proper full request
so that's why we have why
because if you were you know it doesn't
support method doesn't support uh it you
can put query parameters but you cannot
do a you know a post request with the uh
you know with proper encoding of of the
but it can do authentication for example
yes important HTTP response object
directly just like you're Alexa kit
would have and uses the mime type and
everything
great
oh it does okay you can do Euro read and
then import
okay so look what I'm what I'm talking
about here
is for some combination of debugging and
educational purposes to actually see the
raw bytes that are going to be sent in
an HTTP response
does that make any sense
yeah open the documentation page for
your HTTP response
and
there's a way to get a string out and
there's a way to get and if you want
something that is more sugary than that
Somebody by three
okay but I'm just suggesting maybe that
export string works on HTTP response
why export string if anything Imports
string well I'm sorry I meant export
string would work on HTTP no no given a
response specification
you want to know what is the String
version of that response specification
which you could get by using the body
property of HTTP response I'm just
suggesting an alternative way to get
that maybe it's just totally confusing
that make any sense look if I go to
you know import for example
then I've got a list of formats and
you know I can imagine somewhere here
in
I mean by the time we've got warp
formats and things like this maybe this
makes no sense
okay just tell me does this make any
sense or not being able to get a raw
you know HTTP response as a string
from a symbolic HTTP response object
using import does that make any sense or
is it a waste of time
I think it's it's confusing okay fine
okay anybody want to save this or do we
call it
not me I'm fine kill it
okay phone number
okay phone number the story here is that
we've wanted to have something like uh
um a phone number had with properties
for a while
yes I've started implementing it and
there are a few things extra that we can
get out of the library we're using
um okay super duper interesting and and
I mean we can do that it's very easy the
question is whether we
um what do we do in terms of interpreter
like should we have an interpreter type
that returns this object yes and so and
I'm guessing you don't want to break
backwards compatibility to get that
right
why would we need to break backwards
compatibility because interpreter phone
number returns a string
what kind of string does it return so
you you so if you put a okay there you
have examples that don't work but for
example if you do interpreter for number
of uh 217 without the plus one and
without the extension
uh then you
you get the full thing with the country
code Etc
and it uses like your geoip
to figure out where you are yeah
that's what it does okay I've got a
different question here if I want to put
a male 2
or phone number for that matter
hyperlink
in a notebook how does that work how do
I do that
with hyperlink command shift h
I see
but it doesn't Auto
now it can't possibly Auto but wait a
minute so if I say send to
and then I say
me
and then I put in a hyperlink here
and then I put in so if I now put in an
email address
you know here I think it has to be a
mail to cooler
okay well this needs them better
documentation I mean it needs to this
hyperlink thing then would need to
um
well that worked
okay but I would never have known that
that would work so
somehow in the hyperlink dialogue maybe
maybe maybe this is how every
um
um
maybe it's how every hyperlink dialogue
in every application works I don't know
but that's how you put in a mail too
have it documented in hyperlink but it's
quite invisible yeah it's just a note in
hyperlink yeah I could certainly see the
dialogue having a check box to say this
is an email why is it why not put it as
an email address
there's a tab up here that's for email
I'm not sure how commonly wanted that is
to make it a tab
I love it but but somehow or maybe it's
under advanced
this is a check box I think that the
male tube thing supports also having
like title and body
so maybe it makes sense to edit another
tab so that you can fill out these other
things
that would seem useful to me
and that would also have a phone number
I don't even know what what is it what
does it look like under the hood when
you have a link to a phone number
that causes the phone to you know be
able to call that number
there's an analog of mail to for phones
right
I'm not sure yeah there's a phone call
on I don't know if that's actually there
might be a standard or
yeah well let's find out let's find out
and if it is then you know in the
hyperlink dialogue we could add you know
some kind of way of having extra tabs
that for these different things that
seems like the right place to put it in
now in terms of a phone number head
I mean we don't even have a mailing a
mail address head
the phone number it has the advantage
that there are a couple more a couple of
better data we can get out of the of the
library we're using and that gets lost
after we're done we're done parsing it
with interpreter
so things like the you know the prefix
the country code so so some cases we can
detect whether it's a mobile line or uh
or landline everyone is commenting that
it's Tel colon It's the telephone thing
so can we find out what the other codes
like that are you know maybe there's
maybe there's one where somebody's added
where you you know call people in the
metaverse or something who knows I don't
think so yet
or sms's SMS seems to be another one of
those tags
hmm
okay
so those seem worthwhile to somehow
indicate since most of us don't even
seem to know you can do it it seems like
a worthwhile thing
to have as a tab in there but this is
the wrong group to talk about that that
should go to the user assistance meeting
okay now in terms of phone number head
we've agreed for for years that we
should have such a thing
um
which is also relevant to send message
because that will allow one to
I mean I don't know this doesn't strike
me as super high priority but it sounds
like it's a desirable thing
and I'm not sure that Carlo is
necessarily the best equipped person oh
that's cool being able to position I I
already
you already did it that kind of I mean
it's not finished it needs some we need
design review with you you'll need an
icon and a box I guess
uh okay fine well okay so Avery can you
do this and maybe Nick you could
pick this up I mean yeah sounds like
it's a almost done thing
all right I think that was everything
for Carlo
yep to raise anything else nope okay no
I'm sorry thanks bye-bye see ya okay
longer term ild
all right do I need to stick around for
the rest of it we should be done
um
I think yes thank you Charlie thank you
bye
um
okay Linguistics for data set
I mean that's just a project we really
need to push and
I think we've tried to do some some
prototypes at summer schools and things
like that
but I mean he doesn't really understand
what this is about this is about you
know I want to select this column of
this data set blah blah blah and I want
to write that in natural language
and I can see that wolfen Alpha notebook
Edition could benefit from some some
stuff like this
everybody here is silent because nobody
here is really relevant to this project
uh
I I think
anybody got nothing to say about this
I'm yeah I mean I wasn't sure if this
was more related to data set in which
case Jose may have an opinion or if it
was more related to NLP it's more
religion but it's a combination I mean
it's basically given a data set about
which you can say things
how do you express those things in plain
language now in fact Carlo who just
departed built a bunch of this
technology for
um the data upload options of wolfen
alpha Pro
this is a useful thing and I should I
mean
it's going to need a separate well you
should put it on an ild agenda okay uh
with Carlo part of that
Jeremy Michelson part of that
okay
yep
uh
I can imagine there might be a
predictive interface angle to this as
well to suggest things to do with a data
set yes that would be a good idea as
well
I mean the most important thing is it's
just really difficult to you know okay
so a very basic thing is given that
there are names for columns in a data
set be able to refer to the I mean it's
it's things like you know select all
um
fishes longer than
five centimeters
okay and the data set
has well I admit that it might not know
that it's of data set of fishes but it
might have a length
column you get what I'm saying
yes and where would we put this I mean
in in Wayne it is a natural place to put
it but in a standard notebook
I think it would be something like
um
have to fit into query somehow right
maybe so maybe so uh
I mean I don't know I'm making this up
an interpreted query or something
I mean and and in practice what might
happen is you might have your data set
and then you might say
for that data set
I I haven't thought about this I mean
you know some control equals thing
around the data set
I don't know I mean you select the data
set and you press control equals
something or you have a tab in the data
set that gives you a field that allows
you to type in natural language that
seems like a possible thing
in other words you have the data set
where's a good data set for us
um
what what what kind of data set is
Titanic or something here yes or planets
yeah
Okay so
I could imagine something where there's
some you know on hover or something else
there's some little tab here or possibly
there's a ribbon down at the bottom I
mean that would be a nice thing to do
that would be a very nice thing to do
just like in you know images we have
this ribbon that comes up that um
uh
what what am I doing random image is
what I wanted to say
um
okay you know that we have this ribbon
that allows you to do things I could
imagine the same thing with data set
I mean that might be useful in its own
right and maybe we should think about
that
Jose comments
um yes that's a possibility I was
thinking of clicking perhaps in the
on the empty Square yeah that's awesome
right but I mean any of these things
there's a there's probably a nice ux for
entering a query
and then the actual
uh symbolic form of it I don't know
whether it's this or something different
but something like that
um
noticing this comment
here
okay
huh
all right it's interesting
um
all right
um
let's
keep going here
um
all right so I think that's what we
should be discussing here and I think we
should you know this might be easier
than the natural language thing we might
be able to have a bunch of features I
mean I thought we were adding this stuff
is it not in this is 13-2 I thought we
were adding all these things to sort
columns and things and data sets what
happened to that it's that you can right
click on the name of the column now the
name of the column and right click
I actually didn't know that that was
some
well who knew
people are gonna run out of space on
Mars before they know it they have to go
terraform Venus or something never mind
um
they uh
can I ask how it determines whether the
column is sortable because I notice like
if you click on some of the rows in this
data set that you don't get the sort
menu
um okay well let's take a look I mean
how do we get how do we sort this column
here for example
we can't yeah right so that those are
headers
boy we need better ux here because I
really wouldn't have known that there
was that you know I mean I think we
should think about a ribbon or something
because even knowing this right click
thing I completely forgot the right
click that existed
I mean that's a really nice feature
there but I forgot it existed
and I don't quite understand why we
don't on Hover here show some kind of
menu because you know who's hovering
over a data set
see what I'm saying
yes I I don't know all the details of
this but
there are different things you can do
like clicking and going into
a sub data set and things like that so
so that's why we have to be
careful with
various behaviors here
right
12 and click on radius and you see a sub
data set
yes I understand
I think this requires more discussion
separate meeting perhaps even a custom
meeting about data set future about ux
and about the natural language stuff
um we should have somebody from there
from time to discuss those things yes
right
and somebody from ux and so on so okay
another thing for you Avery to deal with
okay
this really is the elegant code
formatting project which I'm fairly
disappointed hasn't happened yet
does anybody know the status of that
I'm involved in that I mean it's it's on
John's plate right now working with the
fonts oh boy I wish there was somebody
else who could deal with that
all right this this particular project
I don't think
makes any sense I don't know if
Christopher would like to comment on
this
you know like like you see pseudocode
written in books right and the question
is
is there a way in which we can take our
code and format it a pseudo code just
like
we format you know math expressions in
traditional textbook form
right but I would say maybe two
actually maybe well okay the first thing
is I think that
formatting our code automatically is
pseudo code I don't think will really
work both because of the styles of
pseudo code I mean like for example in
math right you know it's there's a
certain style in which you're sort of
not just visually but just semantically
what you're supposed to express things
and almost always pseudocode is
expressed in its extremely procedural
style that is just not how you know
people normally write you know
Mathematica and and for example I don't
think I've ever really seen like list
pseudocode or something people usually
just translate it into some very
procedural thing
um the thing that might be useful though
would be we have this um we have this
like cell type called uh program which
actually use quite a bit which sort of
you know just makes some sort of
monospace font with these bars over it
that sort of how you write you know code
that that that might be in an external
language but it might be nice to have
something like that that sort of lets
you write pseudo code you know with all
the different bold the metallic and
backward arrows and weird stuff like
that people like to do but I don't
imagine it would be an automatic thing
what is it program or external language
program external language is the it's
for external evaluate
so is this evaluable no no no
if you want to embed C code or if you
want to say something like oh now run
this command in the command line you
know that's how you would format it
I see
so so one of the questions is
in pseudo code
um
it's
I don't even know maybe pseudocode is
going the way of the dodo I don't know I
I'm I mean you might also be right that
pseudo code was written
and was invented because people would
otherwise be writing assembly code and
that wasn't a way to communicate
anything and so they invented pseudocode
as a essentially a high-level language
for Assembly Language or something
anybody got a sense of that I mean is it
I I would say usually I I take kind of
like usually silica like you should just
look up some examples of pseudocode
maybe if you want to see them but but
often it's you know they don't use any
real syntax or anything and they'll sort
of uh you know they'll use for loops and
stuff like that but then the reason why
it's pseudo code or not code is that in
the middle you know there'll be some
function that you know does magical
things or something where they're
they're glossing over all the error
handling and they're you know stuff like
that
um well I suppose okay so this is an
example
that's a pretty simple one though
there's nothing you know if you look at
like real papers almost always there'll
be a section where they'll say you know
if you know the calculate expected psnr
right there you go
well that raises the question of whether
we should have just a function called
pseudo code
that
people can write
uh this is where the action really
happens
now the question is let's say that was
in the middle because we have a symbolic
language so this you know that thing
could just sit as pseudo code this is
where the action really happens
I mean arguably
okay what this is is a function a sort
of a combination between a comment and a
function
so for example you could imagine this of
X of Y
and then when you look at this and it
could format nicely and then when you
look at this code
it's got that in there until you decide
to edit it and turn it into something
real
in other words if you want to send
somebody a piece of Wolfram language
pseudo code this might be quite a useful
thing because otherwise you'll have a
syntactically incorrect thing with a
comment sitting there and the comment
will go away on evaluation all kinds of
crazy things
be used for this
it certainly could be related I don't
think it's quite the same thing
use that as the label
foreign
if there's actual code there absolutely
but this is the case where there isn't
any code there and where the semantics
actually this is not a bad idea this
isn't yet fully cooked but this is not a
bad idea
I mean
in other words
um
I mean people get the point of this this
the point of this is that you're writing
a piece of code and it says you know
table or I don't know what it says it
says um you know this is applied to I
don't know linear solve blah blah blah
and this thing here has a determinant of
this and blah blah blah and then this is
now a piece of code that
the question is what would it actually
do
and what it should do is
you know everything outside of this
should be somehow Frozen
inactivated
see what I'm saying I was decorated to
natural language the same thing we were
discussing for data set before
well I think this is really just a
comment
this is not really saying I mean this is
saying only vaguely what it does
this is too vague to be interpreted I
think you should issue a warning every
time it evaluates
that's a good point but but what about
it just not evaluating I mean what about
if you put this in your code then this
stuff can evaluate here but the things
outside of the pseudo code just won't
evaluate
is that is do we have a way to do that
to freeze from the inside so to speak
and we have a hold that freezes from the
outside
yeah I mean you can do Insane things
with up values but but well but first of
all hold complete will stop it and also
uh
I think it's it's a little bit sketchy I
think it's it would be better if it if
it you know if you had some outer
wrappers well
I mean if nothing else imagine imagine
this sort of you know weird security
problems and stuff you'd have you had
something that held from the inside
I see what you're saying that it has to
go all the way to somewhere so I mean I
see so I mean imagine the bizarre bugs
if you feed one of these you know an API
function and it starts you know eating
up the cloud in some bizarre way yeah
okay fair enough
well okay so then you'd have an outer
pseudocode wrapper and then inside you
would have
a
um
placeholder code or something like that
yeah or a studio or something maybe I
mean this is a little bit different but
it seems like
one of the main uses for having kind of
real code slash you know real code
that's integrated with pseudocode would
be you're writing some code and you're
sort of doing it bit by bit and you
haven't finished this part yet exactly
but but I mean
yeah I mean maybe it'd be worth also
having some some subsequent arguments
that let you kind of uh
spoof the value or something
that's an interesting idea
right so in other words it's a comment
that's a good idea
where where the difference
I mean again like you say it might just
be a comment like maybe you can just
write this message
point about I don't like I never like
using comments because they go away when
you reformat the code and so on
by the way if you do command shift n
your comments are gone
now when we have these new syntax trees
maybe that won't happen
but this isn't a bad thing to do
I mean honestly I could imagine
this being useful in general of a of a
way to comment your code
in a symbolic comment that's actually
there I mean it it it reminds me of some
of these if compiled rappers or the type
hint wrappers
to just go away on evaluation
I like this idea I mean this is not
fully cooked but I like the idea of um
of a pseudo code wrapper
now maybe what happens is
this this freezing from the inside thing
I admit it's a little bit crazy
um
and
you know for some purposes it's
perfectly okay to have you know
something like
um you know something here where we say
you know the big function
and then we say map that over ABC
you know big deal so it looks like that
and if it's nicely formatted that's not
going to be you know horrifying to see
that
you just know that there's a piece you
didn't fill in
I mean it's really look clearly you can
have conventions that will achieve the
exact same thing
but it seems useful to me
comments from people here
Nick I think this is for you
to try and you kind of step out for a
second but I can pass it along to him
good
um
okay any further comments on this topic
I think the original traditional form
for code thing the only question that I
would have there is uh the font
characters for you know gets a value and
things like this
which could be alternative Syntax for
assignment and so on
am I making sense
Christopher you know what I'm talking
about
um I guess so
I mean like like the algol assignment
operator
I don't know what that is
it's a left Arrow
oh yeah
right it's what people use in studio
code to represent assignment often yeah
here I mean I'm just gonna pull up a
random example of pseudocode no I I know
I didn't know that was from alago
I think it's from alcohol
uses it too
that sounds plausible that they're from
sort of the same time
um
I mean it raises the question
okay I have to say it does raise the
question of whether
if we introduced font characters
or something like that that represented
you know an if then and else that
actually could be written in this kind
of syntax you see what I'm saying
that's a separate point I mean there's
two different points here
um I mean you just mean you get we have
a whole version of the language where
you write things with if and then and
it's all lowercase and stuff like that
what we can imagine is let's imagine
that we said Escape if Escape okay and
that that turned into a thing that was a
blob that looked like an if and maybe
had some decoration around it right so
so it's not so it doesn't look like it's
just a pure whatever
and it just has literally syntax
you know it's like an integral sign
it's a you know like an integral sign
has a has multiple buckets in it right
the the the integrand and the limits and
so on
you see what I'm saying
sure yeah
I don't think this is so crazy I mean
because you know I I've not really
thought about this before but but I I
mean it would seem to me
what do other people think about this
Jose what do you think
I think I see two different ideas here
one is this idea of having an external
thing that will format
the internal code and we'll do nice
things
which I think is fairly which I think
Christopher has commented
is well the only thing
that I could imagine is a traditional
form of if
that looks like this
that Arrow assignment by the way seems
to be APL
oh really okay that was wrong what does
alcohol use it's the uh equal or colon
equals I forget which okay
I'm wrong I think our uses the left
Arrow too for assignment
what a switch
are
oh
assignment operators though but that is
one of them
well in the case
okay we got several different things
going on here one is a syntax character
that does assignment using a backwards
arrow that seems straightforward and I
bet there's one in Unicode and it's just
a question hooking it up
item number one item number two
traditional form formatting of if
is there something sentient we can do
there
am I making sense because right now if I
do Ctrl shift T of this I just get that
right
question is should we get something like
this
seems to me not crazy to do that I don't
know it seems like nobody's paying
attention anymore so so maybe it's time
for us to wrap up
um
anybody here anybody want to comment on
that
I think it's a little exotic
is it useful
[Music]
I mean I can't imagine using it
might be useful as part of something
bigger so I I don't see how we will use
these just for if
well because if you look at these pieces
of pseudo code that I'm looking at here
I mean it's basically procedural
programming stuff
like here's another one
I mean
we could take procedural programs and
format them in this kind of way
because procedural programming programs
do have a traditional form formatting
functional programs do not particularly
right
so so rather than changing traditional
form of something that could be a new
form that does these two problems
right
for some reason this is crazy
okay
um
all right
look I think there is some potential
value in formatting our and having a
traditional form formatting of
procedural programs not that we're
particularly emphasizing procedural
programs but it would be pretty nice if
you could have I mean both ways around
if you could use
special characters basically to make
keywords because there aren't very many
keywords
making sense
yes I was looking for example at C form
of Eve ABC
and and certainly we could do better
if
oh sorry if ABC yes
well that's pathetic
that's just wrong I mean that you know C
form hasn't probably been touched in 30
years
but this is a context language
something like what you have about would
look nice
actually isn't it isn't there like a c
if or something like that
I have no idea but once you're in the
symbolic Sea World I think there's a
scene
is a different issue oh
this is just regular seafoam I mean if I
say C form of you know x squared plus 1
over X or something
oh that's really weird I mean so that
has to have a macro definition and a c
and the C header file
because not wanting to use pow because
of probably because of castes and so on
I I do think that we should explore this
possibility which had not occurred to me
before of having an actual syntax that
uses keywords
see what I'm saying
yep
I expect that in another meeting okay
I've seen what we can do
and you know is there a consistent
syntax with like six or seven keywords
that are that directly translate I mean
they're just Syntax for if and while and
so on
am I making sense
yep
we've got several decent ideas here I
mean this idea of the pseudocode thing
that is a way is a symbolic way of
maintaining information that you can
then you know fill in a program seems
useful all right let's very quickly look
at these last two here and then we're
going to wrap
getting labeled to work in graphics we
have the wrong people here to discuss
that
but people understand what that means
yes
internally in a part of the graphics
rather than all Graphics yes I mean I
mean that we can say Graphics of
something like you know labeled disk
you know hello
right that does not work right now
about to do things like call out
just call out work right now I don't
think it does but I think tooltip works
right seriously
I I think you can just try calling out
because call out is newer so
it might be different but but no nothing
would have fixed yet no I mean these
have not worked and I think they should
now the issue is that Graphics is a full
layout but it has been a layouts best
for cut specifier it's a it gives raw
layout but I think this is one of these
distinctions that is understood only by
implementers and not by users
because I don't know why a user would
expect that this would work and it
doesn't and I don't see why it doesn't
I mean clearly Graphics has things that
are
you know are not
micro specified if you understand what
I'm saying
right there are things in graphics that
this is okay Avery this is something to
take to Brett
and
perhaps it's going to need John fultz
but I want to get this in a separate
meeting and people need and I don't want
a big thing about oh no no we can't do
that because Graphics always only does
the little things you ask it to do look
at axis it doesn't work that way
if it makes sense to you
yeah I can pass that along
okay but I wanted in some meeting I
don't want it to disappear
yeah
okay I don't think we're going to be
able to discuss this at all
we could take a quick look at this
oh boy
that's a lot of stuff here
yeah this section here is the biggest
one this design chestnuts
yeah well there's a lot of important
things here
for another meeting a few things here we
have already done
okay
I'll review this packlet system mutable
data structures I think we can consider
done
I think
um
labeling on maps I would assume
that's now done
do we consider that done Jose
if I put a labeled into Geographics does
it work
labeled labeled or labeled no not
labeled why not
I I think I had never thought about it
before this meeting okay I've always
just labeled to labeled
the graphic the Geographics as a whole
no but I'm saying if I say I want
Geographics
so so for example I use a lot of labeled
as a map but look if we do this if we
say London
you know
this
is this going to work
if it works it's by completely a
surprise to me
absolutely doesn't work right it just
passed to graphics and Graphics yeah so
I mean it's just wrong right and so I
don't even understand why this didn't
pink here why it had an indirect it
blinks in the background it's just that
we are placing the image on top of the
button
I see so it sends that to the messages
right so if you if you do your
background goes to non-gibility
okay fine well I just think this should
work I mean I think it should work in
graphics I think it should work here
right if it works in graphics
Geographics
non-trivial things
well I guess the question is about
position what to put the label but
well right that's the whole point I mean
that's the whole point that's why
there's going to be all kinds of I I've
heard it before it's like oh we can't do
that because Graphics specifies things
precisely we'll look at axes it doesn't
specify things precisely it's figuring
out where to put the labels in with its
you know heuristics or whatever in axes
so it can do the same thing for labels
yeah
I believe in it Gambino right it doesn't
again I've used labor of Geographics a
lot but never inside
right I understand I understand but I
mean okay
all right well we've got lots of stuff
to discuss for another time
um
lots of interesting things some of which
we have we've we've talked about a lot
of oh look tree manipulation look at
that well Ian had to go but we could
take that off the list
no I'm back and we have not uh gotten
xslt type functionality yet so that
I don't know if it needs to be brought
to a ild meeting immediately but right
we know we're doing this in fact that
and proof number film we've done a lot
of stuff on that
um
that's an interesting thing
ways to label elements and Graphics what
do you know should use labeled well
that's the same thing
this is another one that's that's you
know wolfenava has had this for
a Dozen Years
you know automatically generate
reasonable ranges for plots
well I think the user level version of
transmogrify is also
related xslt
mm-hmm
okay well there's interesting things
here I noticed things like revised
number four has shown up twice on this
list
um
yeah we've got a bunch of this stuff
here this was this is done
um so okay lots of interesting things
it's a very useful list
so
uh I'll get it cleaned up for next time
sounds good okay thanks guys see you
soon
bye